welcome back to the iced coffee hour and
today we got two really special guests
the first one is judge von debe you may
have seen her on tv she's a judge who
specializes in divorce cases and child
support payments of all thing and second
we have my lovely girlfriend macy
welcome to the iced coffee house two
polar opposites here we have the
relationship then we have what happens
when relationships go wrong and we got
jack yep so we got the whole spectrum
guys we got marriage we got dating and
we got single so we're going to talk
about how expensive having a girlfriend
is graham do you want to start yeah i
don't really think we yeah yeah so so
first thing for keeping your pet
girlfriend is that you got to make sure
she has food we do love food otherwise
we get cranky lots of naps are important
um you know all those things pretty much
anything you need to take care of a
girlfriend you can find at petco petco
yeah you shop there uh no macy does she
buys her own food there that's what you
know it was funny when we first came out
with our first video everyone was like
graham girlfriends are so expensive and
that was the the time in my life where
like it was all about frugality and
people were like do you know how much
this is going to cost and when you
really look at the cost it's not it's
not bad i mean for you though right
because you take girls on you know i
will took let's say i'm not that
expensive dates what was an ideal date
when you were first getting started in
this just well with macy's overall in
general yeah well it was bad let's hear
it man oh no i'm sure macy has some
experiences here too
no because when graham and i first
started dating all of his friends were
like
oh he actually like takes you out and
stuff so i've heard it's pretty bad but
i never experienced it because i guess
graham must have really liked me yeah
one of my first dates i'll never forget
was in high school and i i remember
i went to the cheesecake factory because
they had these nachos i'd get them with
my buddy nick and they were eight dollar
nachos that were huge like the
cheesecake factory report and we just
split it
and uh but i used to bring my own uh
soda like you know i'd have a soda every
now and then back then but i'd bring my
own and just ask for a cup of ice so i
didn't have to pay the three dollars it
and you did that on a date yes and what
did your date think about it i think i
think we didn't really have a second
date i think we kind of had like a
pseudo shoot
i thought about it through a friend
group and so it was like the second date
was more of like a forced group hangout
uh i think it's fine i didn't see any
issue and saved a lot of money
yeah okay as a girl what would you think
of a guy did that
um yeah i just i feel like it's not a
good look because i i don't know i feel
like then you're kind of jipping the
servers a little bit because like the
server is making money on everything
that you're ordering so just kind of
look at that and that would be my
thought but um i just think you probably
found someone who matched your energy a
little bit or it might have just been
cheaper not to have a soda perhaps then
maybe just have a water that might have
been the smarter way to go but
you really need that soda that sounded
like a performative thing it's like you
bring this soda to show oh look how
thrifty
yeah i also oh the cheesecake factory
also had like five dollar parking and so
i parked at the convenience store next
door and walked over save the save the
parking was that did you have the girl
in your car when you parked there yeah i
did okay i mean that's understandable
honestly
let me tell you guys about my first date
with my wife kelsey and maybe i've told
this before but i'm not sure we went to
the movies and i don't buy any snacks at
the movies because they're too expensive
so then we go in and uh midway through
the movie i hear rustling in her purse
she pulls out bags bagged popcorn you
call the police and then she pulled out
juice boxes and that's when you know
she's the one that's when i knew she was
the one although uh she did admit to me
that you know her mom like gave her the
stuff but uh she was raised that way so
it's like you know yeah say we're the
same person yeah
juice boxes why aren't you
like a capri sun or like one of these
yeah like a caprice yeah like a crippy
sun or something yeah
she also had a water bottle yep yep yep
yeah
she also had candy yeah it was crazy
mustard ketchup everything you need she
made it full on subway sandwich that's
what it felt like to me man yeah i used
to do that um the movie theater where
jack and i grew up used to have these
two dollar tuesdays things and it was
right by uh
winco thank you um we used to go into
winco before and i that was when like
those green military kind of style
jackets were popular with a lot of
pockets so i'd go in there and get the
bags of candy from there and i'd like
put it all throughout the pockets
and so i'd walk in and i'm sure it was
obvious because my
like jacket was stuffed but
yeah that's the smart thing you do jack
what do i do yeah ping pong
oh so you're saying if i if i go on a
date yeah well usually i'll do dinner
usually they'll pay for me no
i don't think i've ever been paid for on
a first date really it's tough yeah i
feel i feel like obligated to pay on a
first date and i'm fine with it so i
know a lot of people that i am dating at
this time would either be like in
college or something and i have like i
work full time you're dating a lot of
people at this time no i'm not but let's
say i do go on a date with someone
they're probably in college you know or
just getting started with a career i've
been working full-time for a couple of
years so it's fine i'll treat them i'm
cool with that and also there is a
little bit of awkwardness it's like uh
like the bill gets you know put down on
the table and you're like okay who's
gonna pay so i just reach for it and i
usually just hand the server my card you
know what it reminds me i actually got
paid i not really got paid to go on a
date this is i had just got my driver's
license
and uh i took this girl to a movie and
her parents bought the tickets so the
tickets were free we showed up at the
movie and then
she handed me like a 20 billion was like
a 50 bill or something like this and
said hey could you go and grab me some
food at the concession stand
and so i did i got it for i came back
and i had the change and she says oh you
know you could you could keep the change
or like you could you could hold on to
the change or something like that best
day ever yeah and so i remember telling
all my friends like i got like twenty
dollars basically so that was my profit
for going on the date really excited for
yeah yeah she didn't care about the
change no no you keep it yeah nowadays
that change would just be like the guess
that it took you to get to the movies
yeah basically with inflation that thing
would yeah and 50 bucks wouldn't have
covered it that's crazy what a lovely
story yeah
so i was proud about that you know what
jack maybe you shouldn't be looking for
girls who are in college maybe find the
girls who did something similar where
they did college wasn't for them and
they you know started their own business
or something because i feel like you
would have a lot more in common with
somebody like that that's what i've said
alex
the thing is i'm a studious person like
i i did well in school i i didn't mind
college i liked high school i got good
grades so it's not like i'm different
from those people i just had opportunity
presented to me and like any person a
lot of people in my situation they would
have taken it yeah but don't you think
work changes you after a year like
you're substantially different going to
school for a year than working for you
yeah especially if you're working for
yourself yeah yeah it's just so then the
person you're dating should also have a
similar experience of working full-time
and like
experience in the real world because
going from college to that is like dude
that's a good point honestly i haven't
really like gone on a date with a girl
who's in that situation and i haven't
been very satisfied with many of the
dates i've been on so jack i've been
telling you this scene that you need to
know you haven't been telling me i swear
have i not asked yeah i think i think
graham brought up something very like
probably almost the same thing you said
that you set your tinder age between
like two certain ages and i said that's
probably too young unless you're dating
one of those people who's worked full
time and they work and they don't go to
school it's too young because they
probably lack life experience unless
they've they've had work experience i
think you could be you could be 18 or 19
with a solid year of work experience
creating your own business or whatever
and be completely different than the
person who's 22 or even 23 who's partied
through college and like hasn't had a
single job in their life the two are
different so that's what i said for you
i think you just need some more work
experience yeah so i'm looking now for
girls with work experience and sent your
resumes over here yeah so we'll see what
happens yeah
i don't know i do gotta say that like
graham and i i feel like our
relationship improved a lot once i
started doing youtube but i started to
understand it a little bit more when i
had like a traditional job because i was
i was like younger in the workforce
right when we started dating i was
almost 21 and i'd been working full time
and yada yada yada yada but when i
started working for myself it's like
totally different than working a
traditional job and neither of you have
really worked traditional jobs and i've
had both experiences you're probably
going to need someone who works for
themselves a little bit because somebody
who works at a traditional job will just
go well the workday's done why can't you
leave it alone or like
i have no problem separating work from
life because they're not passionate
about it like somebody who owns the
business so i feel like you need
somebody who owns their own business
yeah conversely uh when i was with
kelsey and we had a wedding business or
i had a wedding business i would take
her to work with me and she'd help me it
was like she'd help me carry like all
the heavy stuff she wouldn't complain
i'd buy her a dinner you know
not pay her oh i mean you know but so
you know maybe somebody who's ambitious
and willing to help
yeah
alex how did you have her carry the
heavy stuff yeah she wanted to yeah
she's tiny she has no weight to pick up
but that's what i loved about her that
the fact that she was like you know we
would go to to do a wedding and she'd be
like no i want to carry that and i'm
just like i i'm like i don't want you to
hurt yourself
and she's like no i want to carry that
you know she's trying to like
show that she was involved in this and
uh
um yeah so a part of me i think that's
uh so i didn't make her she wanted to
but i feel like that's part of what made
our relationship work even though she
wasn't a you know an entrepreneur in
that sense so let's talk about money and
relationships yeah jack because like i
said you guys are dating you have a wife
alex
uh let's talk about prenups and what's
your guys opinion on that and how
expensive can divorces be
okay let me jump in here because i feel
like i have to jump in first otherwise
everyone's like oh she just agreed with
graham i think for
my situation with graham a prenup is
totally there i think if somebody's
coming into a marriage with assets they
had before they probably are going to
want them after and i can totally
understand a prenup in that case if
you're like both straight out of college
and you have nothing to your name i feel
like sometimes that can be a little
insulting but like with grams in my
situation was different i had had my
roth that would you know at this point
has grown i have a decent amount of
stocks you have your real estate
properties it's nice to feel like those
things are kind of protected if that
makes sense and just kind of to go into
it with a plan but
in other situations like you can
definitely see where somebody's like
that's insulting i have a friend who um
both like right out of college
gonna get married and then um
they both had nothing to their name i
mean like maybe ten thousand dollars
between the two of them and he was like
i want to prenup and i was like yeah
that's insulting especially because all
your money that you have at that point
will coach you just getting it i don't
think so i think it's good to have a
plan regardless even if you're both
starting out with zero because otherwise
the default is you leave it up to the
state and we all know how the state
generally tends to allocate resource i
mean it's just
i don't trust it in the hands of a
random courtroom and depending on the
state's jurisdictions for whatever i
think is better to have a plan ahead of
time whatever that might even if you're
both starting out with zero you could
still
because the whole aspect of a prenup is
agreed upon between both parties so you
could always ask for something and and
it's up to the two to agree on that
together yeah but when you when you have
like especially in this friends case
when you have almost nothing spending
you know half of that money on getting a
prenup
just doesn't seem worth it to me when
you already have the joint banking
account when it's already going to be
probably 50 50 when it's both of your
money that's going in towards all these
assets everything's gonna be joined
but that's a lot cheaper to spend even
let's just say ten thousand dollars now
than potentially spending a hundred
thousand dollars getting divorced and
fighting over who gets what because that
would be cheaper still than the
alternative even if you leave it up to
the state and you say all right
everything's 50 50. i guarantee there's
going to be something where one party
feels entitled or wants another bit that
maybe the other person doesn't agree to
that's more expensive i can see that i
mean i will be the first to admit like
my parents aren't divorced
i don't have very much experience with
divorce so in my mind i just go okay the
state would you know 50 58 but when all
the assets are 50 50 and when you're
earning about the same and you don't
really have very many assets it should
be 50 50. um because everything would be
joint i mean then that's that 10 000
when you go to buy that first home
that's also your money that's being put
into that first home so maybe i just
don't know too much with with divorces
and whatever but i definitely like in
cases like ours i don't get where people
are like you know i feel like you don't
trust me if you're asking for one it
just makes it easier when there's stuff
we're both bringing in yeah how did the
girl in that relationship feel towards
the prenup was she like discouraged by
oh she said no i'm not doing that
because everything at this point is 50
50. because um
because he was wanting to have the first
home just go to him
that they were looking at purchasing and
she's like well dude over i'm making
more than you most of this down payment
is my money
why would you get the house well then
that doesn't make sense yeah i well i
think the house should be split in terms
of who
into the percentage of which person
contributes so if one person is coming
up with half the down payment then
obviously that should be they should be
equally untitled yeah agreed yeah i also
think it's like completely up to the
individual couple everybody's gonna have
a completely different circumstance
going into it and there's definitely
like a scale
of it but like our circumstance might be
different than somebody who has
a similar age gap to how we do it could
be that the younger ones making more
money so i just feel like it's something
that each couple needs to come to on
their own terms i don't think they're
bad no i don't think they're bad i just
see it as an insurance policy basically
like if if you
have a car and you're driving it around
um
and you have a choice just to leave it
up to the state to decide if you're in
an accident how that's allocated or you
could come up with your own insurance
policy and say at least i know
that these are the terms if i were to
get into an accident i think it's a good
idea regardless what do you think jack
for me personally i think it's up to
each individual relationship if they
want or if they don't want i know i
would prefer prenup let's say i
marry a higher earner that's like making
way more than me i would still
definitely 100 want to prenup and
i just think because for me personally
i'm able to detach like my emotions from
certain things but i know some other
people are different like they can see
that as a personal attack if you request
a prenup they could think oh my gosh
they don't you know they don't trust me
with their finances like i understand
other people are different but for me
i'm pretty good at being able to detach
emotion from my decision making and i
think that i would just that's why i
want one with macy on our second date i
brought it up there because i it was the
third okay three yeah second maybe a
little too soon it was our third date
and i could tell i would i really like
macy and i could like tell it was going
somewhere and so i'm like
i just want to let you know as soon as
possible that this is on my mind and
like this is something that's important
to me that way you never think or have
to wonder like oh wow like we're two
years into this and now he's asking for
it like what is it it's like it's early
enough where like if if it's gonna be an
issue it's better to probably flush it
out early on
um and if it's not an issue then great
but at least it's it's early enough
where it's like not a surprise if that
makes sense i think if you approached a
similar thing and just
third third date that's your i mean i've
been on third dates with girls and then
not fourths and i feel like if i brought
up like you know pre-nups that could
mean a lot then yeah like that is such a
unique thing to bring up on a third day
honestly i would bring that up like a
year into the relationship
no no no no no so the thing with graham
and i and why it was the third day is
our first date it was supposed to be
like an hour or two and it lasted seven
hours and the only reason why it ended
was because literally nothing was open
oh yeah that's true everything was
closing yeah everything was closing it
was like
midnight get to that creepy hour it's
like you know the strange people start
walking around the streets people you
guys
yeah we didn't want to be among our
fellow strange people yeah i know but
yeah our first one was seven hours it
was meant to be an hour to our second
one we were just gonna go grab lunch and
i don't think it was just lunch i i
think we'd planned lunch and i was just
gonna show you like to the harbor and
stuff well maybe you did didn't you
cancel work i did that was it oh it was
supposed to be lunch and then you had
work at five and you called in sick or
something like that i'd work from like
one to five because i was working with
that retail job on the weekends because
i was like i have nothing better to do
besides going and go make money um
but yeah i cancelled on it and then our
second date was 12 hours and again it
stopped because we literally had nothing
to do everything was closed again so by
that point it was like we'd spent the
time of like going on like
what we waited
we waited until 1201 so we could call it
like a two-day date
that's cute yeah
yeah we were literally sitting here in
the car
like in the driveway yes be like all
right 1201 yeah i was living with my
parents at that point and they were like
my mom was like looking out the window
and she's like what the hell are they
doing mom seven more minutes
watching you guys because you could see
us sitting in the front seats and she's
like well i just i want to turn off the
lights did you guys kiss when you left i
don't know
ew
oh sorry sorry i didn't mean it tmi yeah
yeah but that third date i was glad you
brought it up then because i think at
this point because i haven't had very
much experience with divorce i mean as
you're saying that it's expensive this i
genuinely have no frame of reference i
was glad that you brought it up early
because i had time to like research it
and really get
you know my bearings on like what
exactly it is what's the purpose of it
and like at a point where i wasn't so
emotionally involved like i am now
that i could kind of detach a little bit
and figure out what it was without
feeling immediately insulted yeah yeah
and it's thorough i mean a prenup you
think of every situation possible from
like you know if if the partner is at
state are they moms
uh the pets
we didn't did we put ramsey we didn't we
didn't we didn't but i think it's just
you know if god forbid if anything were
to happen i mean we kind of would
like i couldn't i would get both no
oh no for the record
that is not the case i don't agree i
don't agree i don't agree i would just
be like you have to be pretty heartless
to like take an animal from somebody i
mean
yeah i just
can't yeah but that goes both ways like
just saying like let's say she wants
both i know she doesn't but or sorry yes
she does my bed i love my babies
then it's that goes the same way like
you wanting to take one or two animals
it's like wow then you're the heartless
the thing is the thing is the animals
decide i think it's pretty clear bailey
is a is a mama's girl and ramsay's uh
daddy's boy
i don't know i don't know whatever right
now he gives me a lot more love than he
gives you
wow gives me a lot of oh bailey spends a
lot of mornings with me so let's talk
this through guys let's let's talk is
alex as a married man do you have a
prenup with your wife uh i do not have a
prenup with my wife i'll have you guys
know we thought about it we talked about
it
um but we are considering doing a post
nup so uh is everything okay
what do you want to talk about alex
what's wrong air it out no no no
everything's okay tell us no no no we um
it's just us here or yeah
only us the prenup stuff i definitely
think it's up to the to the individual
um in terms of like separating assets
and stuff kelsey and i got together with
relatively um similar amounts of assets
um and she helped me build the business
and and she supports me in the business
so um and because of that i i didn't
really care about getting a prenup done
before i got married um
but um talking about like how what
graham was saying i definitely don't
want to leave something up to the state
to decide
so we want to do a post and up just to
kind of put every situation out there
and how we would want it to be split but
we are a little bit different in terms
of you guys because
we kind of keep separate finances but we
kind of look at stuff like for example
if we buy a house if we're both making
the decision to take our personal assets
and put it into a joint asset
we kind of think it's kind of split
um a little bit more evenly even if i
were to have more income or kelsey were
to have more income
at that time we're making the decision
though when we do that but that's where
we're at i think that's good
yeah one condition i think for the
prenup the whole time i've been doing
because i remember i asked you
i think it was on that third date i'm
like are these done like
after engagement are these typically
done like before and gate or like how
does that whole
thing work and you're like typically
it's after someone gets engaged my whole
condition and somebody for whatever
reason this is like this really fires
people up was that i wanted it done
before getting engaged because i just
thought that was kind of a little morbid
to be like so what are we gonna do if
you die huh like where am i so whatever
and like you know what's going to happen
we divorce also like i feel like and not
that i'm unstable about our relationship
at all it's like an extra little thing
that can be like okay we got through the
prenup process together
we're going to be fine you know
it's also weird um
to
to
get engaged to someone and then have
that as like a condition of the
engagement it's like here's a promise
but before we do that here's this first
is like you get everything else done and
then it's just i don't know i feel like
it's probably better to get it out of
the way it's untraditional to do that
but i agree with that it is it's kind of
weird but i'm like i would rather like
at this point
now it's just like okay then we get
engaged then we planned a wedding and
like you just get to play in the wedding
you don't have to deal with the lawyers
you don't have to deal with whatever you
just are planning a wedding
but then it's also the fear of like if
you if that doesn't happen what's gonna
happen to the wedding and like oh if i
don't agree to this we have everyone's
counting on us now and you know then you
have the situations of like ah crap are
you are you agreeing to this because you
just want to
get married and and and not cancel on
everybody or is this like a real thing
so i think it's probably better to get
it done sooner what's the total cost of
a prenup how much does it cost could be
anywhere from like a grand to probably
twenty thirty thousand dollars it
depends on the situation
so they could vary i bet you could get
most for probably
one to three grand what did your prenup
cost 10 grand or no all in it was like
it was
under 15
thousand dollars you guys couldn't have
just like pinky promised or something
thank you promise i would just do like
over text messages would have been
cheaper well yeah see that's what was my
thing earlier too with the with my
friend that they only had about ten
thousand dollars and like that's
literally probably gonna be like i know
ours is a little bit more complex
because they obviously don't have
anything you have a lot of things
but uh it's like that's all your money
and then you're starting doesn't have to
be it could be they could probably find
someone for fifteen hundred to two grand
if if not cheaper probably i just don't
think that a prenup is necessarily like
something that shows that you can't
trust the other person in the
relationship
it's not for me it's not an emotional
thing it's just a smart logical thing to
do and i just see it as just another
step in the journey i think i think some
people see it that way some people see
it as a you don't trust me for me it's
like a contract just like we would have
a contract for what we do a marriage is
very much a financial agreement as well
and it makes sense you would have a
contract but other people would see that
as well
because then you tie in emotions with
with a contract it's not just like a
business decision it's also an emotional
connection that you have with somebody
and throwing in a contract on an
emotional connection is difficult it is
yeah because the grandmother is the same
thing as a marriage contract a gramps is
a lot he's like yeah well yeah yeah he's
like well marriage is a contract i'm
like no it's not it's a commitment you
make to each other so so it's
interesting because people have
definitely very different looks and i do
know like the majority of females who
look at marriages and like wedding and
then you're making these commitments in
front of everybody and and see a
marriage more that way but then i know
more of these finance guys like you or
like a marriage is a contract and then
when we explain to each other because
we've had this conversation like okay
what is a marriage to you and that's
something you you know i guess if you i
don't know someone like graham that's
very analytical you gotta figure out
before that you're definitely yeah mesa
says it's commitment but to me it's like
i'm not going to be any more committed
i'm i'm just i'm committed it's it's
your i'm a hundred percent drama zero
and so it's like well you know for me
marriage wouldn't be it's if anything
it's not trusting like the marriage
because like a mayor's license because
if it's like oh you get these extra
perks if we're married or because we're
married like i just think it's just like
you just do it because you do and that's
what a relationship is and that's like
i don't know that's why so that's where
we kind of had a conversation similar to
you and you see so kelsey and i uh for
those that you of you that don't know we
got married late last year before the
end of the year um but we haven't had
our like our like wedding and so
people when i tell people i'm gonna have
a wedding they're like wait aren't you
married i'm like well well yeah
technically and so what we kind of
talked about or at least yeah i can't
speak for my wife she's not here so let
me speak for myself um
the marriage part of it
that we had
uh
[Music]
late last year that's the contractual
part that basically tells
the government body that we're married
and whoopty do now i get tax benefits
and
all this other cool stuff
the part that means more to me is
having a wedding and then
we didn't do vows last uh when we i call
it eloped i guess you could say um so
when we get married this year when we
have the wedding um that's when we'll do
our vows and and i like macy said that's
kind of where we're making a commitment
in front of like family and friends and
stuff
um but i get it graham it's not that
like i'm any more committed than i am
now um but i'm just
uh putting that commitment in words out
loud in front of family and friends
that's really all it is i think
sometimes it's about also like
vocalizing your feelings too that you're
actually sitting down you're like i'm
vocalizing my feelings i'm gonna make
these va for people that do custom
bounds i'm going to make these vowels
and really really think about it in a
way that you probably wouldn't on the
day to day i think a wedding's about
making those commitments and marriage is
about keeping those commitments and
growing with a person i get that there's
a whole contractual side to it but uh
the way i have always looked it is like
a wedding is where
you're together it doesn't matter if
you're eloping doesn't matter if you're
with family i mean ideally i'd love to
be with family and friends but you come
you sit down you figure out like what am
i gonna promise this person for the rest
of your life and yeah you're kind of
already doing it on the day today but
it's a different thing to actually
vocalize and speak that to the other
person it's like being in a relationship
with somebody for example if they never
said i live i love you i would be like
do they love me you know and it's about
like you're sitting down you're
vocalizing it in a very very um
i don't know intimate way with the other
person so now after seeing anecdotal
yeah love and money stuff we're gonna
actually get someone who has evidence
and statistics and she's a judge and
she's talking about expensive divorces
some crazy stories and all of the other
nuts things about uh divorces let's
bring her on welcome we're so excited to
have you on we've been talking now for
about two months i think going back and
forth on instagram yes i think it
deserves some clarification how we kind
of met but
i was looking for videos uh i've been
watching the people's court a lot lately
and reacting to those videos because i
love the stories and when i was
searching for new people chord videos
your videos came up from support court
and i was like what is this
and so i started watching these videos
they're amazing thank you i absolutely
love them and so we reacted to a few of
the videos and just i think it was you
jack was like we should just dmr or
maybe i dm do you i can't i think you
mentioned it in a reaction video you're
like oh yeah i should reach out to you
vonda and you can come on the iced
coffee hour or something like maybe that
was it and then you reached out to me
yeah and then sure enough you happen to
be here in vegas so we have a lot to
talk about both in terms of legal issues
child support issues maybe we could talk
about uh everything else that's involved
in either marriage divorce we want to
hear all the juicy stories that you have
and how you got to have your judge vonda
b show okay how did that come to be so i
am a practicing family law attorney i've
been doing that for the past eight years
in dallas county
well one day it was i believe it was on
a saturday like new year's eve or
something about three years ago i was
watching tv and this show called the
couple's court came on where it was a
husband and wife acting as a judge and i
was like what is this i've never heard
of couples court then after couples
court went off you had um paternity
court that came on and i said wait a
minute now we're talking
couples court paternity court you have
people's court nobody is talking about
child support that is the most
controversial area of law why isn't
anybody talking about that so within my
office a couple of guys they do all of
my editing and marketing
everything like that so i went to him
and i said hey what do you think about
filming a show where i act as the judge
and i reenact cases that i've seen or
handled personally yeah and they were
like bunda that's an amazing night that
is a good idea so we started filming and
now what you see today three years later
is support court with judge vonda b i
never envision it to be that big because
i literally started it to educate people
about child support laws in texas
so to see it grow from one follower to
over a hundred and fifty three thousand
now on youtube
i think it's pretty cool that is now how
much are you making from youtube now
because i i have a feeling pretty soon
if not already you're gonna make more
money from youtube than you will
practicing law and actually we have
congratulations thank you gosh thank you
i posted on facebook today
on one of the lady lawyers channels
they were asking hey when are you ladies
going on vacation when is your staff
going on vacation i said i actually
closed down december 1st and i'm not
going back until after spring break and
they were like wow
boss wow
but yeah it it's good the ad revenue is
amazing
you should do a sponsor in the middle of
one of the the
how funny would that be i would love it
i would just put it in thank you to gram
relief for sponsoring this in the middle
of the the support court
yeah listen you should be you well we
could talk a little later on the ways to
monetize your channel but
so how did you get into law to begin
with
and why child support i always wanted to
be an attorney ever since i was i
believe two years old i always wanted to
be an attorney my dad retired from the
sheriff's department in dallas county he
worked there over 30 years my mom
retired from dallas county as a
supervisor in the felony courts so it
was one of those things that i just kind
of fell into
and then i married the bailiff that's on
the show well the newer episodes the
older episodes that you see with the
baylor that's my dad
so the newer episodes that's my husband
christopher shaw who is actually a
police officer he is the police chief at
unt dallas in um is located in dallas
and also at the unt college of law in
downtown dallas
so yeah it's something i just always
wanted to do and then child support in
particular i had a personal experience
with child support with my son's father
and it was one of those situations my
situation was not as bad as i've seen
others yeah you know but i was like
why not do this so it kind of found me
you know i had the patience for it you
definitely have to have patience the
personality of course because you have
to have a lot of compassion when people
are coming and talking to you about
child support issues and the mom is not
paying child support or the dad is not
paying child support there are a lot of
hurt feelings that lie underneath that
so once i can kind of counsel through
that then we can move forward with the
progression of the case what was your
first case you ever took i'm sure
everyone remembers the first oh
what is that
the first case i had it was
dad trying to get custody of the child
mom i believe was an exotic dancer
and she was posting all over instagram
you know about her clients she was
posting her body and there was marijuana
that were in the pictures so dad is like
yeah i don't think this is safe
for the child
interesting enough i go to court
and in this particular county in dallas
is located in tarrant county so tarrant
county is like the fort worth the
arlington area
they are zero tolerance on drug usage of
any kind including marijuana the judge
looked at me right in my face and said
miss bailey it's only marijuana and i
said uh judge is only still illegal
he just blew it off
and so my client is confused because
normally
people get their kids removed for drug
usage in that particular county they
will put you on supervised visits for
marijuana using wow okay it never
happened but and i i don't like to play
that whole gender role thing but you do
see some differences
in court i think had the roles been
reversed
dad would have been on supervised visits
but
i think because it was mom and this is
what she did for a living what was she
enjoy if i remember correctly those were
her words she actually enjoyed doing it
you know the judge didn't take her kid
away from her and put her with dad which
i thought was pretty sad yeah do you
ever have a client where you disagree
with their with their request or you it
how difficult is it to represent a
client who you're just let's say you're
against or you just
how often does that come up or did it
come up all the time
i do not always agree with my clients
about 80 to 90
of my clients are men
so when they first come in you know
they're like i don't want to deal with
my child's mom
you're tough you're female you know how
you know you all know how to handle each
other right so it's a matter of
educating first right because remember i
said a lot of them come from a hurt
place whether it was infidelity
um even if it wasn't infidelity just the
mere fact of being placed on child
support kind of rubs people the wrong
way so once i kind of get through that i
can work through their case a lot easier
but i have had some very very difficult
clients some that wanted me to help them
commit fraud
what what's fraud i mean how would you
describe it and you know where you
let's say hypothetically in a divorce
case right in texas
a um
texas is a community property state so
everything is 50 50 anything accumulated
during the marriage well since the date
of marriage is considered community
property well anything before that is
separate property right so
trying to get me to actively pursue
property that you know existed before
the marriage
wow
like that is
total fraud especially when it's
documented right
it's separate property and i just refuse
to do that kind of stuff but you
definitely
get asked i'm pretty sure a lot of
attorneys you know are placed in
situations where your clients want you
to do something that you're absolutely
opposed to yeah do you ever just choose
to not represent a client because you
disagree with what they're asking for
absolutely especially when it comes to
things that are just morally that i
don't necessarily agree with like
anything dealing with discrimination i'm
not going to represent that person any
form of discrimination whether it's you
know race gender
sexual orientation religion because
believe it or not you get a lot of those
situations in that initial consultation
you get a feel it's like an interview
i'm interviewing my potential client
they're interviewing me and i just know
right off the bat if it's anything
dealing with discrimination i'm nine
times out of 10 not gonna touch it right
how much do you get paid per case and do
you get paid based on how much money you
could get for your clients like if i
came to you and say hey i want you know
20 grand a month
would you get paid like a commission
like a real estate agent would get paid
like a commission on the deal i wish you
worked like that like every month you
get
like a small sliver of imagination well
we do in a sense you can get paid by the
month right because you have an initial
retainer that your clients
have to pay you when they come in so for
me the initial retainer if you want to
retain me for a contested matter
depending on
the contested nature it starts at about
10 or 15 000 okay and that's just the
initial wow and then you have to
replenish that every time it gets to a
certain amount so some people do pay on
a monthly basis some pay bi-weekly it
just depends on the contested nature of
the case and a lot of times
the contested nature comes from the
client itself is really not the other
person it's them wanting to contact you
all throughout the day it's 3am you get
this random thought and it's like hey i
want to message my lawyer
at 3am yeah you know i mean i may not
respond until the next day but depending
on what it is you want me to do the next
day it would require time spent on the
case yeah i have to say uh jack i don't
know if i told you this but uh oh yeah i
know you know about this about a year
ago so i've never had a lawyer ever for
anything and uh i was negotiating a
contract and it was i did i didn't know
how to navigate it because it had to do
with with um
uh it was for a startup investment and
so i hired a lawyer to review it all and
he was so helpful and he explained
everything to me and then at that point
i was like well you know what i and then
he drafted up our uh our contract
between jack and i and it was like wow
that's really easy and then all of a
sudden i've had him review every single
thing and uh yeah
that line kind of gets blurred between
now it's like because we talk so often
it's like no he's kind of like a buddy
and i could send him texts and like what
do you think of this and just all hours
it's exactly like you said no he's
getting billed for this but uh or i'm
getting billed for it but uh yeah i
could definitely see that especially
with something as sensitive as uh like
child support oh yeah definitely
definitely and it's at our discretion
what we choose to build for
he your attorney may not bill you for
everything i think
it's basically turning into a monthly
thing now because
yeah
you know and you do have that discretion
so there are some things maybe
you know you can cut the price in half
where it would normally be this you
charge this if it were a communication
where it was five text messages you'll
bill for it but maybe you'd bill for two
or three sure something like that
especially if it's a client where
there's gonna be some longevity and
they're gonna be a recurring client yeah
you'll cut little breaks every now and
then got it so what does your job entail
like is it all child support cases or do
you also take on other sorts of cases as
well oh yeah i do custody cases divorce
cases which child supportive children
are involved that's already an element
within that case and adoptions as well
you can do
name changes so i've had people get
their name changed as an adult i've had
children
their parents have their name changed
for a variety of reasons all those type
of things and property related issues
too which can get really really messy
and they can get messier than child
support cases what was the worst
situation you've seen or the most
difficult it was a situation where i was
coming to court
and
husband i represent a wife husband
brought new girlfriend to court which i
never
advise anybody to do if you're going
through a divorce and infidelity is an
element that they're trying to prove in
a divorce it's never going to be a good
idea to bring
the person that you were cheating on
then went to courtroom oh my
god i was thinking new girlfriend like
they separated your girlfriend so that
was supporting him that was the person
oh yikes okay it was the most
embarrassing thing ever because when
that person comes into court you can
call them as a witness even if they're
not on your witness list
so it's like hey
i want to call her as a witness well
she's not on your witness list she
doesn't have to be she showed up to
court today i have questions for her
right is she obligated to do that let's
just say she just showed up in the
courtroom and she's like no i gotta
leave right now
well i can still call her as a witness
and ask the judge to make sure that she
sticks around because she came to court
and i actually saw that happen i was on
the other end of that where that
happened to me
one people when they come
to court they like to have significant
others and friends just to be there for
moral support however the problem with
that is you can get them called as a
witness
so that happened to me and i said to the
attorney they're not
related to this case at all well they
may be i want to call them as a witness
i was like that is so messed up so ever
since then when i saw that i was like
well
if it's a witness that could be you know
a character witness
have a lot of information that i may or
may not need i want to call them in and
that's what happened on the case it was
bad
wow yeah so what was the outcome of that
case they ended up fighting after
like physically fighting oh my gosh they
ended up physically fighting and just so
you know
family courts fight more than in
criminal courts are you serious yes so
the two ladies were fighting yeah
they were fighting and and the husband
had to intervene no and break it up
right yeah and they went to jail because
you have bailey's name no
yeah they went to jail it was bad they
waited out until they got outside of the
courtroom but yeah it was right there in
the hallway it was like the wildest
thing i'd ever experienced now i've seen
fights in the courthouse
that literally did not involve me i was
at one end of the child support courts
and i'm looking to the other end of the
hallway and you just see people fighting
right and that's normally what it is oh
my gosh it's hurt feeling someone is
bringing someone new to court right
and when i saw that i was like yeah i
can't i can't do this that was just too
much for me and i said to the attorney i
was like you know you need to have a
conversation with your client yeah not
only was it rude it was extremely
hurtful they're going through a divorce
and i think they had been married
almost 20 years that's a long marriage
we're not talking about people that you
know just eloped and been married a year
or two we're talking about a 20-year
marriage there are a lot of hurt
feelings there gosh oh i can't imagine
that oh
well
i experienced it and i never have to see
that again wow so on like these these tv
shows
how real is something like the people's
court i've always been curious like if
some things cause some of these
characters and their characters
how do they find this guy
how do they screen for these people
because we've done our own like we did
the the graham stefan show right people
call in and screening for interesting
calls was so difficult and we just
didn't get enough and so i would imagine
like the people's court they get these
insane scenarios like how much of that
is scripted or played up i mean a lot of
it is scripted but with certain shows
they have where the judge is an
arbitrator so in in which i'm probably
sure is in your you all's contracts
there's an arbitration clause so
arbitration means that you all will go
to an independent person whatever that
outcome is i don't want to say ruling
because they're not a judge
but whatever the outcome is that's final
it's binding kind of like a mediation
type situation yeah so that's what
they're doing a lot of times on these
courtroom shows so some of those
rulings and outcomes they're actually
legit but you really can't tell which
part is scripted versus which part is
unscripted because i've had friends that
have appeared on courtroom shows and
they're like uh yeah vanda that was
scripted but it was portions of it that
were real like they had a real life
issue the reason they were going to
court yeah you know and it's
small claims so we're talking about
nothingness over like five and twenty
five thousand dollars yeah you know if
you broke my vacuum cleaner or you
didn't pay the other half of your rent
yeah
it's about 2500 right something like
that yeah i like this so but so the
downside is you can't do that for child
support unfortunately right so you
couldn't get a real case and just
showcase it and or can you well and
that's the thing i don't know if you can
actually do that per se
but i think if at any point i were to
become an arbitrator yeah and i were not
running for judge which we'll talk about
that here in a second because i am
currently running for judge
um when i if i were to become an
arbitrator or something like that and
have a show that is something that i
would be able to do i just don't know
necessarily the logistics of it because
there is an actual child support court
but that's not necessarily arbitration
so when you go to child support court
they have the attorney general there
that um
helps
mediate
the case between the two people so they
don't have to go to court but if they
don't agree then they'll have to go to
court but arbitration is something
totally different so i mean it's
something i'm looking into long term do
these people get paid to be on the show
i'd imagine if if one person wins it's
like well we're just gonna pay it well
no so a lot of them are just volunteers
really right some of them were my family
members
no they were just excited like when the
show first started we needed talent so
they were like yeah i'll do it i'll do
it and the more popular the show has
become people like hey i want to come on
yeah support court and i'm like okay
so yeah it's
yeah we haven't
we haven't gotten to that point yet
we're still kind of in even though it's
153 000 subscribers that's still in the
growing phase yeah so once we get it to
where we want where we have
a legit company that we're going through
for our talent and everything like that
it'll be a little different yeah yeah i
feel like logistically that would have
been extremely challenging to start up
because you needed an entire i mean you
have to have an audience you have to
have so many people there and you also
have to have a courtroom do you have to
like rent out the courtroom i do and
then what about like the cameras and
everything is it already a pre-prepared
courtroom for shoot filming stuff in
there or is that just like an actual
courtroom where you bring your cameras
in great question so a friend of mine he
is a personal injury attorney so he does
the trucking accidents and car wrecks
and stuff like that so they do a lot of
jury trials
they'll bring in people to do a mock
trial so they'll present their case to
these 12 people to see what the
potential outcome would be so he built
out part of he has a law office in that
building so they built out that
courtroom specifically to bring in the
mock trial jurors and such so the
courtroom is already built out that's
the courtroom that you all see
the um
filming crew that's my crew who that's
it's their own media group they actually
come in set up all the cameras and
everything like that and the talent are
the people that
the audience members they're actually
the talent i wanted to make it be be as
realistic as possible to a child support
court in texas
all the litigants when you have court on
that day everyone sits in the gallery
together
until their case is called so you
literally hear all the cases before
yours seems intimidating yeah
i mean it could be because you're
sitting there you're listening to the
judge give rulings your situation may be
similar to the one that's before you so
it's like man
oh man i'm doing that the judge did this
to that person right so everyone sits in
the gallery because i know i was getting
feedback they're like
everyone is sitting in the courtroom
together i'm like that's how it is in a
texas child support court room yeah my
one i've been to court once and it was
for a tenant who was growing weed in the
garage and then stopped paying his rent
oh and it was so scary because i
remember and uh yeah no i had someone um
helping me so i was representing myself
well no no i did this guy was helping me
out but i had to go like up on the stage
by myself i was so scared and you hear i
remember hearing all the cases he's like
graham stefan versus and then the name
of the other person i was terrified oh
yeah and you walk up there and i'm like
everyone else looking at me yeah uh but
thankfully i didn't do almost any of the
talking the tenant did all the talking
pretty much and uh just dug himself in a
hole because he didn't come with any
information at all that happens all the
time yeah
very common so i've been to court once
as well i uh i like jay
threw a stop sign according to the cops
so like i went up to the stops
yeah okay it was like 11 p.m at night
and it was a four-way stop in a
residential area and you know i think i
did a california stop so yeah i kind of
rolled through it a little bit got
pulled over and decided to take it to
court you know so i could oh gosh
no no no no i would plea guilty i'll get
the traffic and then you can yeah you
can get traffic schools so you don't get
the points on your record also can like
lower the price of your thing so like i
went with like a 250 ticket and it went
down like
so i saved like 30 dollars and i also
didn't get the points on my record but i
remember i filmed this because i was so
frustrated for like going through the
stop sign because let's be honest not a
lot of people come to a complete stop at
stop signs where you feel the car like
you know stop yeah drake calls it a
rolly exactly really not a stop exactly
oh yeah exactly so i figured no one does
that and there was a stop sign leaving
the courthouse and i looked for the cop
that came and pulled me over and i found
him in the parking lot and i watched him
drive out of the courthouse and he did
not stop yeah i filmed it and i went
back to that courtroom and i went up to
the person standing at the door i'm like
i just caught the cop committing the
exact same crime that i committed and
why i'm here today
what can we do how can we make this
right and he's all yeah you're gonna
have to go to like the police department
and then like file all these reports and
everything it's like and what do i get
out of that like what do i get out of
that no but i filmed it it's like it's
posted some random youtube channel i
have someone has to find it yes they
have to we have to make it go what would
they what would the title be of that
it's like cop pulls me over for running
a stop sign then runs a stop sign
something like that yeah it's like it's
like a 20-second clip yeah we need to
change that title make it something
short something yeah because he's
breaking the law something like that
yeah oh my god stop making a rollie it
was frustrating yeah let's talk about
different case scenarios okay okay so
let's say if someone were to be making
as much money as let's say graham over
here
what would that support court like
verdict be like if you were to marry
someone and then split yeah i was
curious about this because let's say in
a scenario where like someone makes
let's just say you know 20 million
dollars a year okay okay the other
person makes 200 000 a year okay
you're living as though you make 200 000
a year even though the one person's
making 10 how is child support dictated
in a scenario like that it depends on
the needs and the lifestyle of those
particular children because child
support in texas it is very simple it's
a calculation
talks about your gross your net you know
you get the net from taking out the
taxes and everything like that
after you get the net how many children
do you have and of course giving you
credit for any health insurance that you
provide right sure
that's
straight like that
well you have nuances
where in the texas family code there are
certain factors that you can ask for to
get what's called above the guidelines
child support so let's say
hypothetically the children have a
special diet they can't eat anything
gluten
right so there's a chef sure that comes
in
cooks these children's meals three to
four times a day they go to daycare at
an exclu in an exclusive neighborhood an
exclusive area um they have tutors that
are world renowned they're in
golf programs with private sessions all
those type of things
those are some of the things that you
can then go into the court and say hey i
need child support a little bit more
than what the guideline would be but you
have to meet that requirement before you
go to court what happens is in that same
scenario people feel like oh they make
this amount of money so i'm entitled to
this amount of child support it doesn't
happen like that i don't know if you all
are familiar with um chris brown has a
child support case out of houston texas
i didn't know that chris brown the
rapper
i didn't know that either he has two
kids now but i had no clue yeah yeah
well he has a child his case is out of
houston texas
and
the mother of their child receives child
support based on
the cap
so in texas there is a cap it's up to
well at that time it was a lot lower but
now it's 9 200
of your net resources that's the amount
of money that you can get no matter how
much money chris brown is worth she's
only entitled to that ninety two hundred
dollar cap well like i said back then it
was like i think it was eight thousand
five hundred and fifty at the time that
that case took place so child support
she received like 2020
2300 something like that it's not a lot
of money well people online were having
reactions to it right they were like
chris brown is worth all of his money
right why isn't she entitled to more oh
my god i'm a movie to texas because it's
so cheap and it's like no that's not how
texas law works she didn't have any
facts according to the court documents
right she didn't have any facts that
described a lifestyle of the child that
required anything extra so
she should get the bare minimum the
baseline well when i say bare minimum
2 300 is not bare minimum for the
average person but considering his
income it was the bare minimum so absent
anything showing that this child is
let's say special needs or
has anything going on that will require
that extra care in terms of funding
you're going to get what they got i
thought it was to create a stable
environment for the child so that when
they go from one house to another
there's not a big discrepancy wouldn't
in that case there be a huge discrepancy
between chris brown's lifestyle and you
know getting paid 2 300 a month and that
is a great question you said chris
brown's lifestyle his lifestyle is not
the determining factor it's the
lifestyle of the child so in texas it's
the the hallmark is what's in the best
interest of the child right it never has
anything or shouldn't have anything to
do with the parents individually because
then we would step in muddy waters right
then you'll be talking about oh well
you're worth this that mean your child
is entitled to this
and that's a scary way to look at things
because even if you're not someone who's
chris brown let's say you're a ceo who
lives in texas
you make 500 000
then if you base that off of you know
lifestyle of that person that makes 500
000
they would exceed what necessarily the
child should receive based on what the
law says so it's on the needs of the
child it always starts there now is that
every state or is that just texas every
state have a maximum every state has
their own i wouldn't i don't necessarily
know if every state has their own
maximum but every state does have a
certain
um
cap in guideline that they use in order
to determine what someone is going to
pay for child support
child support in texas closely resembles
that of california california is also a
community property state like texas now
the
amounts are different so for one child
in texas is 20
of your net resources
in california i believe is 40.
40 40 percent that's a lot it is a lot
which is why
people come to texas
but 40
up to a cap or is it just 40 of that
resource now 40 up to a cap 40 up to
that cap got it okay yeah i have a
question so what if they're making
millions and millions of dollars
but it just so happens that they set
like a
15-year plan to grow their business and
they spend everything on business growth
and then they're only making like a
hundred grand a year like
do can they go after those funds and say
no you're using them to grow your
business or
how does that work that is a great
question so in a situation like that
you'll need a little bit more
of research right so i've seen cases
where
attorneys have hired what's called a
forensic accountant someone to actually
come in and do the tracing and come and
testify to where the money is actually
going and what someone is actually
making because you can separate the
business from your personal
so even though your business may be
making millions you may truly only be
making a hundred thousand dollars which
is typically what people want to be
placed on child support for right
so it requires a little bit in a
situation like that it requires a little
bit more research to actually find that
what i found people that have situations
like that where their business is making
a lot of money and they're trying to say
they only make a hundred thousand they
never separate
the business from the personal what do i
mean by that
they don't have a what do you call it
like a checking system that's writing
them a check every two weeks or every so
often they're literally transferring
money from their business account yeah
to their personal account and when you
do that me as an attorney i can look at
that and do an average on a monthly
basis like how much you're
transferring to yourself and say hey
you're saying a hundred thousand but
according to these transfers and it
links back to your personal account
it's coming up to 300 000
so in a situation like that well you you
don't ever want to do that because
that's just not good for business right
right but then on top of that you want
to make sure that you're separating the
two so you don't muddy the waters got it
yeah they call that co-mingling so so
basically you're saying that that in
order to prove a hundred thousand they
need to actually pull a hundred thousand
from the business to the personal
everything else
stays in the business correct and the
best way to do that is to not pay
yourself personally like that get a
checking system to where you're getting
um a what do you call it a w-2 in a w-2
making sure it's on your tax return
all your documents look good and the
forensic accountant that's the best
person to do that tracing for you if you
have a regular cpa or someone like that
who can do it that would be great too
but it's going to require someone else
independent of yourself to come in and
say that yeah there was a very wealthy
real estate developer in uh in los
angeles he was married i think for only
like two years
and his ex
uh wanted i think it was 75 000 a month
from him to maintain her lifestyle and i
was like what that made that made no
sense to me but she was fighting it and
and the poi and this guy uh uh was
basically he was a very prominent figure
and he was trying to suppress all the
news about this because she the the the
more he said no the more she's like well
i'm gonna i'm gonna blow this up in this
thing and now you're gonna see it on
this publication it's gonna be
everywhere
right right and i don't know the outcome
of that but uh yeah i have to look that
one up the one i looked at recently i
cannot think his name um
it just went viral on social media
people were upset
about him paying so much money i can't
remember how much he has to give her for
life
and everybody was upset about and i said
well did any of you bother to read the
article
he agreed to it and we were on facebook
and they were like wow in the world with
would he agree to that and i said you
have to think the media is only giving
you so much right of what actually
happens in these people's lives right
so if he knows he's worth this amount
because i looked it up i think he was
worth like 4.3
million billion it must have been
billion
it was 4.3 billion i cannot remember his
name right now but he agreed to pay so
much money i said think about it he's
worth all of this there are probably
assets that he was able to maintain in
order to give her that money right so
whatever it is that he has probably
working behind the scenes or on the side
it's the drop in the bucket to just give
her what she's asking for so it just
really depends on the circle wait so in
that case he was paying her a lot of
money yeah it was a lot and it was for
the rest of her life if i believe
i read that correctly the media is only
giving you a very small glimpse of
a 20-year marriage or a 30-year marriage
so it just really depends and a lot of
these situations that you see with
spousal maintenance they've already
been kind of groomed to be set up to
have that lifestyle so at a certain
point if you i guess if you think about
it from a legal standpoint and not
necessarily a moral standpoint sure
because we typically like to look at
everything from a moral standpoint right
but if you look at it from a legal
standpoint if this person has been in
this relationship with you
20 years they've raised the children
you have been able to grow your business
focus on your business do all of those
things
is it
legally
right for them to just walk away i agree
nothing right you know what i mean so
from a legal standpoint i can see it a
little better if it were a moral
standpoint i probably would have a
little bit of a difference like i do
like i do see a difference if if one
person is staying home they're taking
they've taken time off from their work
they're out of the workforce they're
taking care of the children they're
supporting the family
i i think that i mean obviously deserves
to be compensated uh but in like this
this other real estate guy's case like
she was i think in her late 20s she was
like uh she's from europe uh perfectly
capable no kids and 75 000 a month just
seems to me
you know
well how did she get
to the united states from europe was it
one of those things that was like a
mail-order thing
and see and that's another thing you
know when i like to watch the id channel
a lot yeah
so you see things come up like that a
lot you know where people get online
they do like the mail order bribe thing
and it's like hey i give you this amount
of money if you come over here and marry
me so you never necessarily know that
who does that story oh it happens
who pays what's the website the person
the person that's offering you know they
have all so if the person lives in the
united states it's that person that's
paying or is it the person that lives
elsewhere is paying the person that
lives in the united states is paying to
have someone fly out to them and then
marry them yes
and it happens in a lot of
european countries i mean i've seen
it happen a lot right got it if you
watch the investigation discovery i love
you by the way id
it happens quite frequently i mean
at the end of it somebody ends up dead i
mean that's the whole purpose behind the
the um channel investigation
investigation discovery either the
person that came over ends up dead or
the person that brought them over ends
up being i don't want anyone but
yeah it happens a lot more than what
people know and they are literally
paying you know for them to come over
here because
a lot of the time they want the
citizenship right yes so it's an even
exchange i want the citizenship the only
way i can get it is if i marry someone
who's in the states and you have to
think the uh the living conditions in a
lot of places outside the united
anything to come to the united states
and have the opportunities here
so a lot of people and a lot of a lot of
well i don't want to say it's most
probably mostly men but uh you know
they're just you know they want to bring
someone over and they want the affection
and the the love and well hopefully love
but maybe not uh but it's very i mean
it's transactional yeah
sure yeah yeah so i'm newlywed
and i'm congratulations thank you and
i'm listening to these giant words like
spousal support and i'm over here like
my heart's like
what
um
so i'm trying to figure this out
what advice you know i i understand if
somebody deserves um spousal support
after you know like graham said taking
time off of their work to support their
children you know be a homemaker
but
what you know they're like prenups in
place to
protect certain assets but what can
somebody like me do who is trying to set
up for a successful successful future um
what can i do to protect myself from
um over
stated claims maybe of something like
this and i don't make a bunch of money
but let's just say i do how can i
protect myself and uh find something
that's fair or just from a system being
abused
that is a great question um the first
thing i would encourage people to do is
to not start something you can't
necessarily finish the lavish gifts and
the big allowances and not necessarily
saying that everybody does that right
but you can't really start off like that
because if you start off like that and
that's the expectation and you keep
doing it you've now set a trend
and when you go to court hopefully you
never go to court right but if you were
to go to court that's going to be the
testimony he or she started doing this
six years ago and they never stopped
doing it right
so you've kind of told the judge like
this is a status quo so it needs to be
maintained so
don't put yourself in a position where
you're starting something that you
may not necessarily want to finish at a
later time that's the biggest thing that
i see happening in these types of cases
involving spousal maintenance so we
talked about child support child support
is
within the name of itself support of the
child financial support of the child
spousal maintenance is essentially the
same thing it's financial support for
the spouse for a certain amount of time
it can be something as
temporary as six months
it can be something as long as
a lifetime just depends on the
circumstances um a lot of spousal
maintenance cases too just like child
support cases that involve where a
person may have to pay child support
indefinitely for the child's life like
if it's a child that requires a lot of
medical assistance as an adult you know
um something like that so it's the same
thing with the spouse if a spouse is
terminal and they require a 24-hour
nursing staff or something like that and
or they're in hospice and the spouse has
always taken care of those bills and no
met those medical needs then in
situations like that the court can order
that spouse to continue making those
payments so essentially spousal
maintenance is similar to child support
the main difference is that you're
paying it to your spouse or soon to be
expels
giving it to the other parent for the
support of the child something that i
would recommend people doing you
mentioned prenup a prenup protects
assets that existed before the marriage
so you do a prenup before the marriage
actually takes
takes place you can also do a post-numb
and prenups is short for prenuptial
agreement post-numb short agreement
means after the divorce so anything that
has been accumulated or may be
accumulated during the marriage you can
write it out in your post-numbul
agreement that it maintains a
characteristic of separate property
i've seen that happen too like people
got married they had a house
wife wanted to keep it they did a
post-numb and it was clear that the
house was going to go to wife at the
time that a divorce would occur yeah my
understanding though prenup also
dictates the terms of the marriage
itself so you could you could dictate in
a prenup this is to you know this income
is supposed to be separate property this
is going to be divided like this alimony
could be this it does um as long as a
prenup does not violate public policy or
is illegal or anything like that it's
going to be upheld in court a prenuptial
agreement cannot address the issue of
child support right at all um it can't
address you know what will happen with
custody or anything with children but um
anything absent a violation of public
policy or like i said illegal then it's
going to be uphill because it's
essentially an a mutual agreement
between both parties yeah so what if
there's
like a relationship between two people
and one person makes a lot of money
let's just say like 500 grand a year the
other person makes you know like 60 70
80 000 a year and then
the person that's making 60 70 80 000
isn't aware that the other person is
making 500 000 and they live at a low
standard of like they're not a low
standard but like an average income
and then they get married and then they
get divorced but the person making all
this money never discloses to the other
person that he's making this amount of
money and continues to live at that
level jack come on
obvious question ever
what it is a great question though
because why is it an obvious question
how does the other person that you're
marrying not know how much money you
make oh you would be surprised that's
why oh you would be surprised graham it
would be fun he actually asked a very
[Laughter]
how do they not know really how do you
know oh you will be surprised you'd be
surprised graham but they get married
and they have no idea how much the other
person makes it that happens a lot what
yep you end up not i mean it's the same
thing like when people are divorcing
it's like all the skeletons come out
during a divorce you find out about
children that you didn't know existed
that were either created before your
relationship started or created during
your relationship i mean i've seen that
happen same thing with assets you know
hiding assets putting things in other
people's name although you are the one
who is the consto custodian of it it's
in someone else's name it's offshore
that kind of stuff happens so it is very
very possible that a spouse could be
marrying someone and not necessarily
know
all of the money that is attached to
them or the debt because a lot of people
you know they live off charge cards i've
seen that happen too in divorces living
off charged cars living this very lavish
lifestyle and then next thing you know
you get these notices in the mail that
are like three and four months like hey
the bank is getting ready to seize your
house wow you're like wait a minute i
thought that my spouse was taking care
of all of that and turns out they have a
mountain of debt there is no income so
it can happen both ways
oh i kept telling jack like there's no
way you're getting married without the
other person knowing how much you make
but uh that's assuming everybody is
honest i mean because everybody's not
all right i guess so what so what
happens in jacksonville right in this
case in terms of a divorce like with
spousal maintenance yeah like you live
at some lower standard of living that
when you could you know achieve with the
joint income uh and you just never
disclose how much money you're making
well it really depends so in a lot of
divorce cases especially ones that don't
involve children
um
it is encouraged that you go to
mediation well in order to
settle in mediation you have to disclose
everything and in a lot of divorce cases
everything that's not disclosed ends up
getting revealed some type of way
especially if the attorneys do what's
called discovery discovery is just a
fancy word to say hey give me all this
information so you well texas law has
changed so you have to give this
information up front now it used to be
where you sent it to the other person
they had 30 days to give it to you now
from the time that a case is filed and
the other person responds or files an
answer to the case they have to produce
all of these documents up front to now
kind of circumvent the scenario that
you're talking about because then you
would have that lower
income spouse pretty much walking away
with nothing and the spouse that has
more money walking away with everything
so in my opinion the way that texas law
kind of does it now they're called the
initial disclosures where you have to
give this stuff up front
i think it kind of helps with making
sure that doesn't happen as often i
don't want to say it doesn't happen
anymore but it doesn't happen as often
as it used to got it the best solution
to that jack i just came up with this i
could just pay you less
why are you saying this is directed
towards me i'm just saying so my
question was purely hypothetical that
way it wasn't it didn't have to do with
anything but just in case
i think we should probably you know take
it down a little bit you don't give me
anything
i don't pay you anything no you don't
well well maybe okay we could we could
we could keep it that way sure
graham can i get a pay cut too while
we're at yeah
that is hilarious
communication is key in any relationship
and i see that falling by the wayside
in a lot of cases they end up in divorce
they just don't communicate with each
other you have to communicate you have
to be open and honest about finances i
cannot stress that enough
being open and honest about finances
good bad and ugly you have to disclose
all of it whether you want to or not
yeah so something that we've talked
about is we potentially want to adopt um
or have a child and the one thing that
kelsey and i as of now and obviously it
might change is we want it to be 50 50
in regards to parenting right okay and
it may not go that way depending on our
schedule or you know whatever life may
bring our way and we'll discuss it at
the time but i mean assuming that
we go 50 50 on on taking care of the
child here is there anything that like
we can do because you said you can't
include children on a prenup you ca so i
that doesn't mean that we can
sign some sort of document that says if
we split you know
we're just going even like like there's
no money exchange like i can't do that
is that that's illegal or
well i wouldn't necessarily say it's
illegal it just violates public policy
in terms of putting it into an actual
agreement
if you all are going to adopt though
you can do um what is that called um i
saw it happen in another state it didn't
necessarily happen in texas they had an
actual agreement between the two of them
that outlined what the parenting roles
were going to be not upon the time of a
divorce at the time that they were
married guys people should do that when
they have a kid to begin with well i
mean i don't understand a parenting
agreement so it's kind of like but
in texas
you usually see a parenting agreement
after someone is placed on child support
this situation was different they
adopted a child and outlined before any
divorce or child support or anything
like that what the parental roles were
going to be for each parent and i
believe this case i want to say arkansas
but i could be wrong
but it was a same-sex couple it was two
females and they outlined what each
person's roles would be when it comes to
parenting with the child eventually they
did go through a divorce and it got
really messy because then it ended up
not having anything to do with the
parenting roles it was the parent that
carried the child trying to say that the
other parent was not the parent oh
so they were able to the courts were
able to use that parenting agreement
between them to show that okay
this is the parent because if you didn't
think it was the parent you wouldn't
have agreed to that right right but yeah
putting something you know it doesn't
necessarily have to be in writing right
if you're talking about adopting a child
with your spouse
but i think it is important for parents
to outline what the parental roles are
you should not just let one parent take
100
role on everything that's you know
feeding the child clothing the child
taking the child to school picking them
up from school um
scheduling their doctor's appointments
dental appointments one parent shouldn't
do that solely because that's when you
start getting into
trouble and you mentioned you want to
co-parent or do a 50 50 split everything
you do during your marriage has to be 50
50. and that number i really don't like
the term 50 50 because nothing really is
50 50 in general right someone at some
point is always going to do more than
the other one but as long as in terms of
parenting you guys are sharing
responsibilities as long as you do that
you should be fine but you're not
getting a divorce we're you're not
getting a divorce so you don't have to
worry about that well thanks and so
though the other thing that you were
mentioning too about not establishing uh
a trend right when it comes to to
certain
gifts and stuff um to avoid maybe abuse
of the was it spousal maintenance yeah
uh so you're saying this year what i
could do to avoid that is maybe not give
any christmas gifts no that's not what
i'm saying
you can give christmas gifts just keep
it under ten dollars
you know you you just have to there's a
difference between you know showering
your spouse with gifts every now and
then anniversary birthdays
versus you know some of the things i've
seen where they have an allowance of ten
thousand dollars a month oh geez
right that's their allowance and that
doesn't include the cost of health
insurance car note
car insurance it doesn't include any of
these things because i've seen that
happen
and when you maintain that lifestyle
like that for some of these 10 15 year
marriages how can you then get to court
and say judge i can't afford
to keep maintaining this well what have
you been doing for the past 10 or 15
years
so that's where you kind of get into
trouble with that
interesting so what you're saying is
just
you know as long as you're being fair as
long as you know you're not trying to
max out credit cards live above your
beans uh it should hopefully the court
should find a good solution for you guys
to have a fair split should that happen
oh yeah and ultimately you won't when it
doesn't involve kids you want it to be
equitable you use their word
earlier you definitely want it to be
equitable you want the other person to
be able to live you want the other
person to be able to
um provide for their children if
children are involved if no children are
involved you want them to be able to
maintain some of the same things that
they were doing so it wouldn't
necessarily be equitable
um if they're they aren't able to do
that anymore or for the flip side that
other person it wouldn't necessarily be
equitable to them if you've maintained
doing something for so long that they've
become accustomed to that's a part of
their lifestyle to then sweep you know
snatch the rug from under their feet i
don't think that's equitable either so
yeah just be fair
what about this what are some red flags
that you've seen in relationships to
watch out for
a lot
first off
um if
the person has another child jack
if the person has another child
if
they are talking bad about
their child's parent
that's always going to be a red flag
always
and it never fails i have cases where
you know they were dating they thought
they liked each other and that stuff was
going on and then next thing you know
they're in child support court because
they have a kid and it's like okay
history told you
right that you were going to be in this
position because they used to say these
type of things about the other parent to
you so that's a huge red flag to pay
attention to another red flag to pay
attention to is a parent that does not
take care of their kids at all you
definitely have to pay attention to that
don't take care of their kids at all or
do it when it's convenient for them
or they're not providing any financial
support whatsoever or
not really in the child's life
those are some things you know
that will definitely if you're not
careful will end you up in child support
court i mean there are plenty others but
those are the ones that pop immediately
into my mind when you're thinking about
child support wow i agree i think the
ability to split amicably with someone
is uh it tells you a lot about their
character for example let's say i'm on a
date with this girl and she starts
negative talking your ex immediate red
flag for many reasons for many reasons
yeah
yeah it is a red flag because just think
about it there is something good you can
find in everybody right at some point
right
and to just speak negatively about them
now the relationship may have ended bad
but you dated them so at some point
there was something
to say about them so you either just
talk about you know the situation and
how it ended maybe what you could have
done differently because it's two people
right you play a role in it but to just
bash and trash talk the other person
yeah you know what always
reminds me of of one date i went on this
this must have been like eight years ago
a while ago but i went on this date and
i forget how we even met but uh went on
the date the entire date was her talking
about her ex yeah the entire date and
then it was revealed towards the end of
the day and i've never in my life walked
out and just like wait this is the one
you walked out on yeah told me about
this yeah did i tell you that yeah but
you said on the podcast did i
maybe maybe did you go did you say you
were going to the bathroom yes yeah okay
but she had also revealed something
about like she was also dating someone
else but it wasn't official and she
didn't know if he liked her or not and
i'm like why am i here oh so that's
another
myself to the bathroom because here's
the thing it's like i and and here's and
she ordered something expensive too yeah
yeah yeah yeah so i always if if i'm
going out to eat i i like it where
they're not ordering like the most
expensive thing on the eye because i'll
order kind of cheap and you know i'm not
like looking at what you put but you
know if she's getting something that's
like 50 and mine's 15 you know maybe
there's something something there but uh
yeah i got something cheap and she's
like orders like all the expensive stuff
and so i'm like i'm gonna pay for that
and i'm gonna ask to split it because i
got my thing she got hers i left right i
left and that's another one never done
that but yeah and didn't she text you
after yeah she had she texted me
afterwards at first uh yeah she kept
texting me i i didn't respond and then i
think she texted again like it was like
a week later asking like another
question about meeting up right i don't
know it was some weird stuff i wanted to
meet up with you
it was such a long it was such a long
time i don't remember exactly the text
but it was along those lines oh yeah you
definitely dodged a bully yeah she's
crazy
she was crazy
oh yeah
i remember her first text afterwards
like she was like what happened what
happened and then like five days later
something she was like would you be
pissed if your best friend pretended
that their grandma was dying but it
turned out they didn't i was like what
she texted you that's something it was
nice oh get out of there man get away
nowhere
lying dead grandma's not dealing with
that
what questions do you have for us we
always like to flip it on the guest
whatever you want to ask us you could
ask us okay what made you all get into
this podcast i think it's so awesome
i'll follow you on instagram oh cool
thank you yeah you're welcome yeah so
what started the iced coffee hour what
started the iced coffee it was jack's
idea and jack wanted to start a podcast
and and i figured well you know if if
it's just an hour a week and we could
just you know goof off and and film a
video and monetize the conversation we
may as well do it and uh i really
enjoyed it and there was a period you
know a few months in where it just it
was so slow and jack was like now gotta
keep it going and we posted every week
and we did not want to miss an episode
so we just kept it every single week we
have not missed an episode have we
missed idiot no no we've never not
posted no and we've posted late maybe
twice yeah and i figured a long form
content type of more like candid uh
video would be a better way for graham
to connect with his audience and really
like appeal to his base
and the iced coffee hour i've noticed
for those that do like watch all like
every single piece of content whether it
be like graham steffen show iced coffee
hourgram stefan even this to family the
iced coffee is a lot of people's
favorites because we really like we get
in to like the nitty-gritty here yeah
and i feel like a lot more personality
comes out on the iced coffee hour
because it's more candid yeah and every
episode is different which is what i
like we we we rarely have the same
person on twice when we do it's always
about a different topic right but uh i
just keep the engagement yeah yeah but i
remember telling jack in the very
beginning one of the biggest benefits of
the podcast for me is getting to meet
new people and it's strange by the way
if you meet someone
it's hard just to say hey uh do you
wanna grab dinner yeah do you wanna like
uh get grab lunch get a coffee because
it's boring but anytime you say hey i
wanna come on the podcast everyone says
yes oh yeah no one would say yeah let's
do a dinner no no one does that the
podcast everyone said yes yeah so i mean
it's great happy that you reached out to
me and i was like wait a minute he has a
blue check next to his name yeah who is
this yeah
and so i had to look it up and i was
like okay
this is pretty cool because a lot of
people since the show have reached out
to me on youtube and i love meeting new
people
it is like
my thing i love meeting new people
because i don't really think you
necessarily meet a stranger per se you
just haven't crossed paths yet yeah
right so um yeah i i'm excited yeah i
was definitely gonna say yeah when you
said podcasting yeah when i say you're
in vegas i was like we're going to vegas
for our anniversary yeah that's perfect
but see had i said let's grab dinner or
something or let's grab a i wouldn't i
you know let's grab it harder for you to
even ask that in the first year
yeah then there's always like what's
what's the motive behind you like why
dinner at least with the podcast like
come on the podcast we could talk right
but uh yeah
so it definitely helps but you'll find
that youtube is probably some of the
best networking ever because everyone is
on youtube and everyone now in my life
has come from youtube pretty much
everybody that i could think besides
family it's like everyone i talk to now
is uh youtube yeah everybody that has
reached out to me have come through the
youtube channel
through instagram some some sort of
social media
medium yeah now i'm gonna tell you what
you need you should absolutely start
posting these videos on facebook if
you're not doing that already oh yeah i
don't do it as often you gotta get
consistent with it you gotta post every
episode that you're doing uh edit it
down post it on facebook okay uh then do
instagram reels same thing just post
that to reels and then tick-tock okay
that one video that i watched with the
with the lady what was it she didn't
want to work and her husband was making
more money and she was like oh that was
the guy who's a mechanic yeah yeah oh
yeah and you said well you could go work
and she's like i don't want to work
yeah that would go for that video if you
took that down the best 60 seconds of
that video
and you post it on tick tock that's a
million views i sure will i sure will
like i said i'm running for judge so
that was so what does that mean exactly
we haven't heard this so i'm i've been
practicing law for the past eight years
now i'm running for family court judge
um it's the 255th family district court
that's in dallas county so pretty much
this court needs restoration like
literally
um from you name it from a judge banning
people like attorneys out of the
courtroom which is a big no-no because
the courtroom belongs to the people
right
doing things like that showing bias on
the bench clear bias you know different
things like that i just was tired of
seeing it
and
in my community i'm born and raised in
dallas there's a specific area in dallas
called oak cliff i don't know if you all
are familiar with football or anything
but the south oak cliff high school is a
high school located in oak cliff
they just won the state championship
and it's been what 60 61 years or
something like that so it was a big deal
right so
i'm one of those people i'm prominent in
my community i'm well known i'm always
giving back
and i thought to myself how can i say
that i'm a true leader of this community
if i sit back
and watch something like this continue
to happen
so it was like wanda you're just gonna
have to walk away from your nice salary
your nice comforts of what you're used
to you're gonna have to sacrifice
yourself and make a difference so
instead of being someone that complained
which that's not me at all i don't just
sit up and complain about anything i'm
going to put myself out there so that's
exactly what i did so now i'm running
for judge when i win i would actually
take the bench on january 1st of 2023
which means i can no longer sit as judge
von to be
but
exciting new things coming for the show
but what does that mean you get replaced
if that happens um in terms of my show
yeah well yes and no so i want to give
you too much
it's going to be fun all right the next
part of the what do you call it the the
growth
of support court with judge fonda be
it's going to be exciting all right but
the thing is my only thing is it needs
to be you oh well you are not yeah if
you're the person between the two people
it's if it's not you the show is you
can't do the show not well i don't know
i don't know it's heart well like you
can't replace a judge judy like when she
goes she goes it's like she's made the
show i feel like you've made the show
thank you i appreciate that depending on
who the person it is you get and where
you actually spin it it can be very
successful okay and that's where we're
headed with that okay so that's why i
said i can't tell you too much because
it's going to be awesome trust me i will
still have some role with the show okay
because as a judge i can still consult
right like how we're sitting here on the
podcast yeah so i can still do the
reactions and the educational segment
after the fact okay but who will
actually be in that role will be a
little bit more exciting all right all
right see i liked your approach because
i felt you were really fair and nice oh
yeah and like you weren't demeaning to
the people but you were you you said the
same things that i was thinking yeah so
that's what i liked about it yeah and
it's going to be like that the direction
that the show will go once
i win okay um i think you'll like it
still
you're gonna say all right
this is awesome
why didn't i think of that when we were
talking on the podcast i think you're
gonna like it you just have to stay
tuned all right but until then you will
get all of me
all right we expect it all right
absolutely anything else you wanted to
bring up or ask us i don't have any
other questions
just thank you for watching thank you
for coming on over here really really
nice meeting you nice to meet you too do
you like coffee do you both of you like
coffee um not as much as i used to when
i was in law school when i was studying
for the bar i kind of got away from
coffee to keep myself from being so
jittery got it and so now i drink coffee
maybe once or twice a year once or twice
a year yeah what about what about your
husband he doesn't drink coffee at all
at all no he doesn't like it what
wow okay
well then i wish your day started off
right yeah i i was i was uh going to uh
bankroll coffee was going to provide you
with some complimentary coffee if you
would like it
so the offer is there or we could gift
it to somebody else please gift
i would love for a coffee drinker to
drink it okay i could give it to you and
you could decide who's worthy of it
that's a good idea my my mom and my
sister both love coffee
well thank you so much for coming on
really nice meeting you thank you guys
for watching pop a sub pop a like yes
yes subscribe you want to tell them to
subscribe he's like 15 of people don't
subscribe definitely like subscribe and
share the video okay and tell them to
get their free stock down below in the
description that's worth all the way up
to a thousand dollars when they use the
code gram and sign up for public say
that
what he just said what to say that's it
well thank you so much freestyle
drop in the comments
yeah that's it that's it that's it okay
close enough thanks guys
i'll see you thanks oh that was so fun